but you have you have high praise for
Elon you just said that he's way smarter
than a trumpet right what he did to him
he's like you're right he's Satan I
won't bring him back
like they're getting that's 3D chess I
love it
it's I man I couldn't I think thank you
Elon beautiful job who do you who do you
put in
in the in the in the class of people
that are fighting for Freedom whether
you say tucker whether you say Elon
whether you say these names who would
you put in that category who else would
you put in that category I mean we got
Rogan we got Elon we got who else would
you put in that well I got mad at Joe
Rogan five years ago six years ago
because I've known Joe uh you know since
since for 25 years I mean before he was
doing Fear Factor Rodney starting UFC
he'd done news radio and we've partied I
mean we have uh We've like you've seen
the movie uh hangover yeah well you've
actually done that
like uh you know uh I don't it's like
the most interesting man in the world I
don't often do drugs but when I do is
literally so me and Joe have uh we have
done some stuff and it's I love Joe and
I always thought there was something
about him people like why do you love
that Joe Rogan he's a smart yeah I told
people 20 years ago I said that guy is
super smart because he let me tell you
that guy he sits there and plays Dumb
and does all that stuff and it's all
calculated and he's a good guy he knows
all this stuff we talk every day I mean
you know they they get mad at him about
that we text constantly you know every
day and we send people articles and
stuff he just and that's why I got mad
at him when he was kind of going the
Liberals about six years ago and kind of
playing games they were kind of
recruiting him and and I was just like
Joe knock it off
stop you know about all this and then he
got more hardcore again and he went the
right direction and then they did the
lockdowns he said screw these people to
talk to him going after him and now
they've got Alex Jones that's that's
more controlled and more controlling
himself not controlled by them they got
L shows 2.0 you got Tucker Carl so they
mess with him Alex Jones 2.0 Joe Rogan
Alex show she pointed I could just all I
want is Victory and I just I mean I'm
actually proud of the fact that uh I've
Been instrumental in waking up Joe Rogan
you know he listened to my show a lot 20
something years ago he called in on my
show on 9 11. that said it's
irresponsible Alex you're saying the US
government blew the buildings up I saw
them blow it up I saw the local news say
we're going to blow up building seven it
was on the news that day the back then
stuff wasn't archived so it wasn't until
four years later all the news put their
archives online when when when storage
got better and you can pull up building
seven you know we we're gonna blow up
building seven and we watch it come down
it's on the CBS News ABC News CNN we're
going to pull it that's hilarious silver
scene later on PBS you said he blew it
up so so Joe you know used to call me up
and go hey man I mean he really he knew
I meant what I was saying but he just
wouldn't believe how bad it was and then
about
I'd say by about 18 years ago he was
really awake sort of studying it and
they just couldn't he didn't want to
believe it anymore and then he kind of
got out of it about 10 years ago
he kind of did some shows debunking
conspiracies a TV show that he that kind
of turned into the dark side for a while
and then I started getting in his face
about it calling him up and stuff and
saying hey man you're not you're not
stupid you know you know you're I'm uh I
told him I said you're you know I'm
really admire you I know he's a great
guy I said you're a punk you're acting
like a punk and and I said if you keep
doing it I'm gonna go in there and start
attacking your ass and then uh and then
we kind of went back and forth and stuff
so I went crazy and I went too far and I
apologize to her but I mean now I'm just
so proud of him so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]